will get ready to step into the Magical
World of Disney there is so much going
on there with the immersive Disney
Animation it's bringing your favorite
characters to life this is in the shops
at crystals on the Strip at Harmon our
Lauren degrady there for opening day and
there is so much going on there Lauren
there is
indeed I
are Frozen right now Dorothy McKim joins
me here okay wow I mean how is it like
to be an animator have all this come to
life really quick it is so wonderful to
be immersed in our movies All Surrounded
and it is so glorious and so okay
um roughly 50 minute show 45 films 40
bucks I mean talk to me about you know
you guys already had like a preview last
night too but today is opening day talk
to me about what to expect when you come
inside
everybody will be so excited here when
they come in because we have over 45 of
our films that are in this experience
and you're going to be surprised with
wristbands that light up and they'll
activate it with what you'll see up on
the walls and also the floor is
activated so there's surprises we have
bubbles which is very exciting everybody
loves Bubbles and there are just so many
surprises and all of our films that
everybody will be able to relate to no
exactly and I think we're starting up
here we're now with uh Encanto so yeah
it's just an immersive experience that
flows through it like she said the floor
moves as well yes and tickets are
available as well yeah tickets are
available you can go online
disneyimersive.com and buy your tickets
and come see us definitely and this runs
through opening day now to the
summertime lots to see here come on out
we're going to keep moving through with
a Wonderful World of Disney for now back
to you guys
so fun incredible she even talked about
the very first Disney character was
Steamboat Willie that kind of turned
into Mickey Mouse yes on the ship yeah
oh gosh that looks so fun what a deal
too I don't think that's a bad ticket
price are you kidding me right what did
they say 45 Disney movies yeah that's an
incredible experience and I was
wondering what makes it so immersive and
obviously it's the sound it's the video
but she was talking about the the floor
and the bubbles I mean you're in it I
want to dance with the Beast
hahaha